we have a voicemail number you can call
any time of day
2192 david p a very
important issue that i am glad to have
the chance to address
vaccine passports take a listen to this
voicemail
hey david is anyone of any political
clout actually talking about
instituting vaccine passports we keep
hearing people being worried that they
may
require these things but who's actually
going to implement this
yeah okay so this is a very important
question
number one we are increasingly
hearing that the united states doesn't
plan to institute
some kind of a mandatory
government-level
vaccine passport if individual
businesses want to require vaccination
if schools want to require vaccination
if colleges want to require vaccinations
there would be nothing new or unique
about that
i had a list of vaccinations i had to
have to go to college
um that's it's just it's simply not new
or controversial in any way
if other okay if the u.s wants to
institute
a vaccination requirement for people
coming from other countries
there would be nothing controversial
about that and also if other countries
want to say if you're an american and
you want to come
do tourism where we are in our country
you need the following vaccines
that already exists you are required to
have a yellow fever vaccine to travel to
some south american countries and to
some african countries it's been going
on for decades
i didn't hear don jr talking about it or
people calling it the mark of the beast
or whatever
uh to go to saudi arabia i believe
during
i believe it's during the hajj maybe
it's year round you need a meningococcal
vaccine
okay i could go on and on this
isn't new it's not controversial the
term
vaccine passport is admittedly a new way
to refer to this
but we have had globally depending on
what school you're going to or what
country you want to travel to
a whole variety of required vaccines you
don't have to get the vaccine
you're just required to have it if you
want to do this thing
countries will have rules about who can
go to their country that's always been
the case
much the same way that trump did his
majority muslim country travel ban
he could have done a vaccination
requirement or the state department
could
so this entire issue is completely blown
out of proportion there is nothing
controversial here
proof of vaccination has been around as
a requirement for different elements of
society
traveling state departments domestically
college etc for decades
and this is another one of these
creating an issue out of nothing listen
if delta says you need a vaccine to fly
and you don't want to get the vaccine
then just don't fly delta figure out
some other way to do it drive
if you can or fly an airline that
doesn't require it
if your kid's college or your college
says
here's the list of vaccines and it now
includes the coveted vaccine
uh wonder to yourself or ask yourself
why is the list now not okay but it was
when it didn't include the covet 19
vaccine
it's a pathetic distraction i wish they
would stop they're making themselves
look stupid there's nothing
controversial here
we have a great bonus show for you today
china is creating its own digital
currency
this is the first major economy that is
doing this we're going to talk about it
and the implications
there are more and more calls to boycott
yes boycott
beijing's olympics and there are also
concerns about retaliation from china
and we now have a situation in the
united states where half
50 percent of new covet cases are coming
from just five
u.s states which states are they and
why is it that they are so heavily
concentrated in just these
five states all very important issues
that we will discuss
on today's bonus show two ways to get
access to the bonus show real easy
become a member at the coupon code
better21 is available if you want it
become a patron at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow if you're already a
member you can also become a patron
if you're already a patron you can also
become a member you are allowed to
double dip
for now that is not against the law
although
we're keeping a close eye on it i will
see you on today's bonus show